vous êtes beaucoup de fans m'avaient un
petit peu vous aimez bien vos femmes bah
oui je les aime beaucoup locaux ouais et
alors c'est des questions de fans marche
c'est ton vrai prénom
oui c'est un génie de t'appeler lavoine
comme les légumes écoute un peu au
départ ça m'a un peu moi tu sais les
quolibets d'enfants les manifestations à
bâle mais vie je me suis fait et puis
j'ai demandé à changer de nom avec mon
producteur me fais écouter c'est de bien
chanter déjà en vain être non plus tard
si la tanche c'est vrai que tu viennes
qu'une princesse des fidèles ouais bon
sans rire tes fidèles
ouais non vraiment vraiment sens mais
ils sont cools des [ __ ] très 7 a
fait quoi de chanter avec les élèves de
la star ac pour la cinquième année le
coup tu sais moi je chante pour les gens
qui sont en face du poste 1 ils sont 2
devant je fais pas de discrimination je
suis pas quelqu'un qui fait de la
discrimination sur les routes sur
l'audience et ça fait comment ta maman
michou n'entama elle a pas de lunettes
bleues mes cheveux tu as déjà été en
prison je me suis fait arrêter tout
autant mais parce qu'en banlieue de
départ c break comme disait
10 je suis fait arrêter exactement pour
le même genre de petits larcins
la pique et des litres de lait n'était
pas d'origine maintenant 50 ans du lait
écrémé ou deux mais tu es plutôt thé ou
café
je suis plutôt café et il c'est vrai
qu'on fait de la meilleure musique quand
on prend de la drogue n'ont ni quand on
en prend un lit quand on en prend pas
oui quand on est au malheureux je prends
ça nous vient comme ça d'un coup on sait
pas pourquoi je pense que faut être
assez sérieux pour faire de la musique
quand même ça se fait assez le matin
après il s'en fout ils sont fort bien
quand le faire et puissant quelle
couleur sombre
elle n'a pas de couleur noire elle est
aussi allée en bois thème quoi au lit
dormir j'adore j'adore le lit d'une
assez longue surrénales le lycée mont
lieux préférés je travaille beaucoup les
thèmes quoi au lit
j'aime le contact de la couette et et
j'aime gnl comme ça non parce que j'aime
beaucoup rêver j'avais des rêves tes
cheveux c'est des vrais ouais c'était
hier soir hier soir je chantais je dis
pas qu à arras et à je suis votre
voiture je rentrais chez moi
ouais genesi tellement banal me souviens
toi de mauritanie commettre leurs ports
entrées de la via un mec qui mettait pas
longtemps l'amérique
mais voilà les droits de péage paris
béthune 20 minutes c'est normal en même
temps c'est pour bernard thévenet
d'époque du football locaux il est sympa
johnny très thabeet ou paris c'est pour
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'europe
écoute moi qu'est ce que tu fais pas de
vacances
les vacances c'est vrai pour moi c'est
donc le moment où je peux rien toute ma
famille en profiter à nos stocks shell
en afrique cette année et
j'ai vraiment passé beaucoup de temps
dans le chai avec les massaï et je
trouve que pour une petite gamine de 7
ans c'est important de voir d'aller
d'aller voir les cultures d'autres
d'autres monde un monde est magnifique
le couleurs de penser le berceau de
l'humanité s'est déjà mis un string et
comment j'ai fait de décharger
commercial lémanique est allé d'adjamé
astres et oui pour le film de vincent
ravalec cantique de la racaille c'est
vrai qu'il est très élevée je sois tout
nu et alors ils m'appelaient c'est
rigolo disait marc foutu le feu assure
jeffrey panu un bon alors je te coupe la
mito montage il disait c'est même pas la
peine d'y penser
c'est marrant que tu parles de ta vie
puis sa dernière question des fans c'est
time grosse [ __ ] c'est con comme
question non franchement pas je pense
centimètres raconte pas traîné
leur décès